Welcome to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Six, Theme Spotlights, Episode One: the geography of Denmark.
Chapter Six is different from the others.
It is a collection of themes, from geography and sights to the royal house, religion, schools, health and climate.
We begin with the land itself.
The Danish landscape was shaped by the ice ages, which, in several rounds, completely covered the area that today makes up Denmark.
The ice melted about 11,500 years ago.
Denmark is one of the world's lowest-lying countries.
On average, Denmark's area lies 34 metres above sea level.
The highest natural point is called Møllehøj and lies in eastern Jutland, about 170 metres above sea level.
Denmark's area is about 43,000 square kilometres, and is mostly covered by fertile, clayey and sandy soil, but in a few places the landscape is very different.
On the eastern side of the island of Møn, for example, there is an almost 130-metre-high cliff, Møns Klint.
Also the island of Bornholm and the group of islands Ertholmene, which lie out in the Baltic Sea, differ from the rest of the landscape.
The islands are the only places in Denmark where you can see the bedrock.
Denmark used to be covered by forest, but today about 60 percent of the country is cultivated, in Danish opdyrket, which is almost two thirds of the country.
An exam may ask it as a fraction.
In Danish, Jutland is Jylland, Zealand is Sjælland, Funen is Fyn, the North Sea is Nordsøen, and the Baltic Sea is Østersøen.
Denmark consists of a peninsula, Jutland, and 443 named islands.
But people live on only about 80 of the Danish islands, and the rest are small and uninhabited.
The largest island is Zealand.
South of Zealand lie the islands of Lolland and Falster.
Because of the many islands, Denmark has a very long coastline, about 7,300 kilometres, and nowhere in Denmark is it more than 52 kilometres to the sea.
The North Sea is the largest of the seas around Denmark.
It lies off the Jutland west coast and is also called Vesterhavet, the West Sea.
North of Zealand and Funen lies the water Kattegat, which in the south is connected to the Baltic Sea by the three straits Lillebælt, Storebælt and Øresund.
It is only in South Jutland, the southernmost part of Jutland, that there is a fixed land border, of 68 kilometres, to a neighbouring country, and that is to Germany.
The climate in Denmark is especially marked by the location by the North Sea and the short distance to the coast everywhere in the country.
From the Gulf of Mexico, a permanent stream of warm water, the so-called Gulf Stream, is carried towards Northern Europe.
Because of the Gulf Stream, the climate in north-western Europe, and particularly in winter, is markedly milder than the climate in other places in the world that lie just as far north, for example Moscow or southern Alaska.
The coldest months, January and February, have an average daytime temperature of three to four degrees, while the warmest, July and August, average about 22 degrees.
It can however become both considerably colder and warmer.
The lowest temperature ever measured in Denmark is minus 31.2, in 1982, while the highest is 36.4, in 1975.
Next, the bridges.
Denmark is today connected by several bridges and tunnels.
In 1935, the first bridge over the Little Belt, Lillebælt, between Jutland and Funen was inaugurated, and in 1970 another Little Belt Bridge opened.
In 1997 the Great Belt Link, Storebæltsforbindelsen, between Funen and Zealand was inaugurated for rail traffic, and the year after, in 1998, for car traffic.
In the year 2000, with the Øresund Link, the Øresundsbroen, the Øresund Bridge, a fixed connection was created over the water of Øresund between Zealand and the neighbouring country Sweden.
Denmark's capital and largest city is Copenhagen, which lies on the eastern part of Zealand.
Today about one third of Denmark's population lives in the capital area, that is, in Copenhagen itself and the municipalities around Copenhagen.
Aarhus, with about 300,000 inhabitants, is the largest city in Jutland.
It lies on Jutland's east coast and is Denmark's second largest city.
The largest city on Funen is Odense, with about 200,000 inhabitants.
It is the country's third largest city.
Denmark's fourth largest city is Aalborg, with about 125,000 inhabitants, which lies in North Jutland.
The fifth largest is Esbjerg, with about 75,000 inhabitants, in West Jutland.
The most important raw materials in Denmark have in recent years been the oil and natural gas that lie in the seabed under the Danish part of the North Sea.
Since the end of the 1990s, Denmark has exported more energy than the country has imported.
The extraction of oil and natural gas therefore has relatively great importance for the Danish economy, even though its importance has been falling.
In December 2020, the Folketing decided to end this production by 2050 at the latest.
This is due, among other things, to a wish for a green transition to renewable energy.
Here is your recap for Episode One.
The ice melted about 11,500 years ago.
Denmark is one of the world's lowest-lying countries, on average 34 metres above sea level.
The highest natural point is Møllehøj, about 170 metres, in eastern Jutland.
The area is about 43,000 square kilometres, and about 60 percent is cultivated.
Møns Klint is almost 130 metres high.
Bedrock can only be seen on Bornholm and Ertholmene.
Denmark has the peninsula of Jutland and 443 named islands, about 80 of them inhabited.
The largest island is Zealand.
The coastline is about 7,300 kilometres, and nowhere is more than 52 kilometres from the sea.
The North Sea is also called Vesterhavet.
Kattegat connects to the Baltic Sea through Lillebælt, Storebælt and Øresund.
The only land border is to Germany, 68 kilometres.
The first bridge over Lillebælt, between Jutland and Funen, opened in 1935, and a second in 1970.
The Great Belt Link, the motorway link across Storebælt, opened in 1997 for rail and 1998 for cars, and the Øresund Bridge, Øresundsbroen, in 2000.
The largest cities are Copenhagen, Aarhus, Odense, Aalborg and Esbjerg.
The Folketing decided in December 2020 to end oil and gas production by 2050.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
In which year was the motorway link across Storebælt inaugurated?
Option A: 1986.
Option B: 1998.
Option C: 2010.
[DA] I hvilket år blev motorvejsforbindelsen over Storebælt indviet?  A: I 1986  |  B: I 1998  |  C: I 2010
The answer is B: 1998.
It appeared in the June 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: I 1998
Question 2.
In which year was the Øresund Bridge, Øresundsbroen, opened?
Option A: 1970.
Option B: 1985.
Option C: 2000.
[DA] I hvilket år blev Øresundsbroen åbnet?  A: I 1970  |  B: I 1985  |  C: I 2000
The answer is C: 2000.
It appeared in the November 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: I 2000
Question 3.
How large a part of Denmark is today cultivated agricultural land?
Option A: Almost one sixth.
Option B: Almost one third.
Option C: Almost two thirds.
[DA] Hvor stor en del af Danmark er i dag opdyrket landbrugsland?  A: Næsten 1/6  |  B: Næsten 1/3  |  C: Næsten 2/3
The answer is C: Almost two thirds.
It appeared in the June 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Næsten 2/3
Question 4.
How high is Denmark's highest natural point?
Option A: About 170 metres above sea level.
Option B: About 470 metres above sea level.
Option C: About 770 metres above sea level.
[DA] Hvor højt er Danmarks højeste naturlige punkt?  A: Cirka 170 meter over havets overflade  |  B: Cirka 470 meter over havets overflade  |  C: Cirka 770 meter over havets overflade
The answer is A: About 170 metres above sea level.
It appeared in the November 2021, May 2023 and May 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Cirka 170 meter over havets overflade
Question 5.
Where is Denmark's highest natural point located?
Option A: In North Zealand.
Option B: In South Jutland.
Option C: In East Jutland.
[DA] Hvor ligger Danmarks højeste naturlige punkt?  A: I Nordsjælland  |  B: I Sønderjylland  |  C: I Østjylland
The answer is C: In East Jutland.
It appeared in the November 2022 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: I Østjylland
Question 6.
Over which water did a bridge open in 1935?
Option A: Øresund.
Option B: Storebælt.
Option C: Lillebælt.
[DA] Over hvilket farvand åbnede en bro i 1935?  A: Øresund  |  B: Storebælt  |  C: Lillebælt
The answer is C: Lillebælt.
It appeared in the November 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Lillebælt
Question 7.
Which of the following cities has the most inhabitants?
Option A: Esbjerg.
Option B: Aarhus.
Option C: Aalborg.
[DA] Hvilken af følgende byer har flest indbyggere?  A: Esbjerg  |  B: Aarhus  |  C: Aalborg
The answer is B: Aarhus.
It appeared in the June 2026 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Aarhus
That's the end of this part.
Well done.